five two two five let's go out to
Charlie in Orlando what's up Charlie
hey John hey George it's a pleasure to
talk with you guys you too man what's up
yeah so my question is regarding my
in-laws on recently married and uh I
have their numbers pulled up and
everything like the question is for my
wife and I is if we're gonna have to
help my in-laws financially with
retirement they're wanting to retire in
about five years they have a whole
financial Fiasco and we're currently
working on baby step two we're plowing
through our debt we're doing pretty well
and we're just wondering are we gonna
have to help them and their financial
mess when we're trying to still work on
ours you know buildings into step three
and unless it's something they can
figure out on their own you know we're
just kind of worried about the future
basically for both parties have they
asked you for your help
so they have not
then this call is over yeah there's not
a lot you can do man
not a lot you can do and I hate that for
you what made you feel like we've got to
take on the burden of their financial
future
it's kind of that whole you know
obviously we want to live like no one
else so we can later live and give like
no one else mindset and we've they my
mother-in-law has kind of opened up to
wanting some help with Finance but my
father-in-law is like I don't have any
debt just my wife oh wow
you know that kind of scenario and has
he always been like that that's a scary
how long have you been married Charlie
so I've been married for only a few
months but they've been married for at
least 30 years they bought their house
in 92 in Orlando yeah I'm gonna give you
some wisdom I've been married for 21
years okay yes sir
I would stay as far away from the inner
workings of your in-laws marriage as you
possibly can
yes sir unless both of them not one of
them if both of them sit down and say
will you help us
right
um otherwise you're going to get
triangulated into this mess and you're
gonna end up it's your wife's gonna have
to choose between you and is the whole
thing goes sideways I think the best
thing you could do right now is um what
I used to tell my daughter when she was
four which is you worry about you
and let them worry about them
yeah that's how I felt too like one time
she came to my wife needed gas money it
was kind of one of those is this going
to get bigger than gas money one day and
yes it was kind of yeah that's it's
scary is the gateway drug to more
enabling it exactly so here's what you
can do because I don't want to leave you
an alert just being like haha you can't
do anything there is something you can
do that is way more powerful and that is
you live out this plan in such a way and
talk about it openly to where they go
huh tell me more about that that
snowball thing you guys are doing
because you seem to be like on fire and
something's different you guys want to
make some changes that is going to be
your best path to getting them to change
versus writing them a check every month
hoping that it's going to solve anything
and George George just gave you the
optimistic version here's the other one
when you say I'm not going we're not
going on that cruise that you just
planned that we're supposed to pay for
because that's not in our budget and
it's not a part of our debt payment plan
or we're not flying to wherever for
Christmas because we are working on our
on our debt and they're oh my gosh are
you kidding me you're telling me this
stupid plans more important than your
family yeah because we're playing a long
game yeah and if you all opt to do
Christmas without us y'all can do that
because y'all are grown-ups but we as
for me in my house right so either way
they're either going to see the light
and the fire inside of you or they're
going to be on the other side of your
boundaries that you've put up either way
they're gonna they're gonna watch you
your behavior is going to be a language
for them and
um that's going to be the best initial
teacher until they both sit down and say
all right
what are y'all doing will you teach us
and that's a whole different
conversation
that's what I've gathered because my
mother-in-law is more receptive like
she's actually already seen a marriage
counselor by herself and there's kind of
the from what we've gathered already
that he's not even agreeing with that
either that it's our problems why should
someone else help us fix it and all
right so I'm going to give you some more
wisdom
and it's gonna be the exact same wisdom
I gave you earlier
get out of that marriage deal with your
own right that's our goal we have our
own place uh next Friday and I was I
kind of felt I just needed that
reassurance I guess is it's okay to step
back and start our own family tree and
really be an example like you said and
grieve with your wife as she is is sad
that her parents marriage is falling
apart
and that their finances are a zoo and
they're both exhausted and instead of
celebrating with you two they're trying
to tread water it's gonna be hard on
your wife and you know you're all in
with her and so there's gonna be some
grieving that goes along with that
naturally right
yes sir yeah man well good for you man
hey thanks for being a guy that cares
and loves right
um but man that one's getting other
people to do something I want them to do
I don't think it's ever worked out in my
life and that seems to be it makes me so
frustrated the engine that maybe
Congress runs on like our whole thing is
I'm gonna get you to do something you
don't want to do
um it just doesn't ever work right it
never works unless you use force and
that always ends up in well you know
John you're really in shape and John's I
was like dude you got to move your body
you got to work out but John can't want
it more than I do you know what I mean
John just can't be like dude you're
gonna work out you're going to you can't
just tell me to go to this I think the
last time we talked I was like I will
give you a workout plan when you've gone
for 30 days there we go I can't word up
yeah but what you can do is I'm like man
John you look good you're like yeah I
just I've been on this Real Simple Plan
I'm happy to send you the plan now I'm
kind of intrigued that doesn't mean I'll
do it or when Whitney says man John's
got humongous muscles how exactly how
does he have those and you don't and
you're like I'll talk to John right
versus you being like dude you're real
flabby yeah you gotta hit the gym man
never works right now that's not gonna
work and I do um I do think most of the
time those sometimes that's based out of
Shame right but I think a lot of times
like Charlie here it comes from a good
place oh yeah like salt of the earth I
don't want your life to be like this
and it's hard when you have to look in
the mirror and say they didn't ask my
opinion on what they're doing with their
life right well and the older you get
it's harder to change I mean when you're
Now 60 and you've lived out the same bad
financial habits for 35 years and never
worked on your marriage trying to do
that now is just even harder which is
why I'm extra inspired when I meet a 65
year old on the debt free stage what
they did versus the 22 year old is like
dude old dogs can learn new tricks oh
you really gotta want it yes at that age
and I think it's an important lesson for
all of us to learn um you heard me
joking with Charlie but not joking to
stay out of his parents marriage I'll
take that one step further
we do this with our bosses I bet they
just they're probably doing that because
you know they have this thing we have no
idea why they're doing that I bet that
congressman is just doing this just
because you don't know and what you do
is we spin ourselves up
getting in other people's head and
deciding why they just did what they did
we do that with our spouse who do that
with our kids you just did that because
you don't know and so again as I told my
my sweet daughter Josephine when she was
little you take care of you get out of
people heads get out of there judging
their actions maybe you could be curious
once in a while but take care of you
take care of you and if we all take care
of ourselves
it's amazing what the world could look
like right it's a good word and George
go to the gym this is the Ramsay show
we'll be right back
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined by George camel triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
talking money we're talking marriage
we're talking your mental emotional
health your work whatever you got going
on Triple eight eight two five five two
two five and
um since I'm hosting the show today
I'm gonna take a minute
um and talk about George I'm real
excited about this I got a brand new
book coming out called building a
non-anxious life
um if you pre-order today uh as Dave's
been saying we'll bribe you we'll send
you a whole bunch of stuff the pre-sale
helps us out as it just helps me out as
an author
um it helps with the rankings and all
kind of things but here's the deal
you know it and I know it
that we've reached a point where
we can't continue to live these stressed
out burned out fried out anxious lives
at some point this stops
and my hope is instead of
um not changing the oil on your car and
driving it until your engine just turns
into a brick and you can never drive
that car again that we're all able to
pull off on the side of the road read
this book
follow the plan to help live a life
where your anxiety alarms are not
ringing off the hook all day every day
it affects your kids it affects your
workplace it affects your home it
affects your longevity it affects your
marriage it affects everything and we
have to be honest about the ways we've
been trying to tackle this problem over
the last decade it's not working
when um they discovered penicillin and
started applying it to uh folks who had
infections deaths from infections fell
off off the table that was a cure it
fixed that problem right
um to some degree
this is different what we've been trying
to do and trying to do and trying to do
is not working and so what this book is
is me taking all the Neuroscience all
the grad school all these sitting with
people for the last 20 years and my own
path that's been up and down all over
the place and backing up 30 000 feet and
saying all right let's reimagine this
problem and let's let's actually put a
real solution out on the table and the
solution's not easy it's it's very
similar to the baby steps like you don't
just snap your fingers and walk out in
the street and go I'm dead free and your
money goes away you gotta you gotta you
gotta pay the piper right you got some
work to do
um and you still have to make budgets
for the rest of your life right
similar with dealing with your mental
health your emotional health your
anxiety but this book gives you a path
um
it's 20 bucks and I'll send you 75 bucks
of free bonus items including a free
talk I just gave
um as well as ebook audiobook you get it
all it's go to ramsaysolutions.com
and George since you're about to be a
new parent I'm gonna give you two copies
just for free just because I love you
wow just gonna hook you up actually a
friend of mine has been like dude can
you give me a copy of John's book I'm
like dude I don't have it yet he won't
even give it to me how can I give it to
you I they gave me one and they said
under penalty of death can this leave
your uh your your dang it soon there'll
be like boxes everywhere that's right
but this is all the rage among the youth
and this is a book which is cool that is
for everyone yeah you know some of our
plan it's controversial everybody wants
to build a non-anxious life like how
could you be like nah that's not for me
I'll take the anxiety yeah for 500 hours
you know I'm kind of down with the with
the chronic stress exactly burnout's fun
for me but Dave has been preaching about
money for years you are doing for
relationships and mental health and I'm
so excited to see how this book helps
people John I appreciate it man and for
the thousands and thousands of folks
have already pre-ordered it um
you all know I talk too much when I host
this show I find myself speechless
um as they send the numbers over and
it's just been very humbling and very
overwhelming and so I'm really really
grateful
um ramseysolutions.com pick it up and um
thank you thank you thank you all right
let's run out to Salt Lake City Utah and
talk to the Great and Powerful Patrick
what's up Patrick
hey good how are you guys doing this
morning we're partying man how about you
I've been doing well thank you
what's up
so um my life just finished optometry
school and uh we also want to maybe
start having kids in the next couple of
years uh we've got about 160 000 in
student loan debt plus our home mortgage
and no other debt
um what's the fastest way to pay that
off so that she can maybe go half time
um and with that should we pay uh more
into our retirement or less into our
retirement and more until our debt is
paid down or paid off
great questions well I'm I'm happy for
her that she's she's done with this now
is she working yep she's all done yeah
she started working about two months ago
awesome so what's the household income
now
uh per month or per year we're about 245
a year I'd love to hear that that's the
kind of numbers that will help you get
out of 160 000 of debt so you're right
you're starting to Grapple with like we
wanted to have kids we want to do
retirement we want to pay off the debt
and what we found is that when you focus
on just one thing like a laser
it is done much faster and you're
actually able to finish and so I would
not do any retirement investing you guys
have plenty of time to invest for the
future right how old are you two
well I'm 53 and she's 29. so the time is
a Little Bit Lots for her not so much
for me okay have you been investing at
all over the course of your working life
I have I had to give up some of it when
I got divorced about 12 years ago I have
about 280 almost 300 000. awesome well
that's uh quite the Head Start so the
question now becomes how much of this
245 can we start shoveling towards these
student loans
and my guess is if you look truthfully
the answer is most of it
yeah the real question is how little can
we live on
mortgage is 2500.
um and then we make about
bring in I don't know what the about 15
about 20 a month yeah about 20 it sounds
like a lot right it is a lot it's a lot
so just imagine if you put like fifteen
thousand dollars a month towards these
loans how quickly could you pay them off
um well I have a little debt chart here
and I think I could get out of my our
student loan debt within the slope of
the line is saying about a year that
sounds about right if you get intense
about this and so think about where you
are a year from now if you just do this
you're completely debt free and in a few
months later you're going to have a
fully funded emergency fund and then
you're back to investing and we're
talking what 14 months from now you're
there
so should we do the company match at
five percent and six percent on each of
our uh jobs or should we
or should we just let that go
I well the the idea of it I'm letting it
go here's what here's how I see it
instead of just doing a measly match
you're going to come at this thing Full
Throttle 14 months from now doing 15
percent
instead of three four five percent so
put pause on that number one it's gonna
put a fire under your butt that's what I
like it because you're like dang I want
that match I can't believe it it's a
stupid tax on yourself you're attacking
yourself for having gone into debt and
it's going to inspire you to get done
with this real fast
you're withholding the dessert until we
get get in shape a little bit you know
what I mean so this is it's it's twofold
number one five percent of 245 000 is a
heck of a lot of money that you could be
throwing at this debt so number one your
debt's done faster and number two it
makes you angry at the debt which makes
it gone faster and gets you back to
investing more in a shorter amount of
time
okay
um why do you want your why is your wife
want to go half time
after just finishing grad school
uh because she's 29 years old and she's
like I'm gonna want to not be able to
have kids if we don't hurry up and get
them
all right do you already have kids from
a previous marriage
I have one he's like in his early 20s
he's 21. so and he lives you know he's
outside of the house so you're getting
back up on the Merry-Go-Round you're
gonna go again
yeah yeah she wants to have kids I'm
like you know I wanted to have more than
one so let's uh let's consider that I
would recommend from now on saying we
want to have kids
otherwise it's gonna sound weird
yeah well we do we both want to have
this there you go look at the Patrick
I'm excited for it we'll use that to
fuel this debt-free journey and we're
going to help you out with that if you
go to ramseysolutions.com student loans
we have an awesome student loan Hub
there with resources our team is
updating on what's going on out there
we've got student loan payoff
calculators all kinds of things and so
you and your lovely wife go check that
out at ramseysolutions.com student loans
and call us back when you're debt free
we'd love to celebrate with you
okay we're gonna do that thank you very
much absolutely hey man you're on your
path to Freedom Patrick everybody
listening
that's what the show's about it's about
freedom
and not in like the Star-Spangled
underwear kind of way but in the but
John the government said they're gonna
forgive my loans that's freedom
that's probably the worst accident I've
ever heard in my life thank you but
it's about not owing anybody anything
and then you can go part-time half-time
full-time whatever you want to do
because you don't owe anybody anything
Freedom we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
this is a segment I like to call this is
my confession all right
I've been going to counseling I'm trying
to be better as a human and admit my
faults and so at the end of the last
segment
George gave a perfect
King of the Hill uh uh accent do it
again George dang It Bobby
something like that so he did it perfect
and I knew he did it perfect but I
couldn't think of the show and so
instead of saying that's a great accent
for that one show I can't think of the
name for it I just said hey George
that's the worst accent I've ever heard
that wasn't true it was perfect I
couldn't remember the show and I was
kind of embarrassed because I love that
show thank you John it's fantastic thank
you for that apology that ends and this
is why we tell you counseling Works guys
this ends the segment called This is My
Confession all right let's go out to
Naima in Detroit what's up Naima
Hi how are you guys thank you for
clicking my call thank you so much for
calling we're doing great what's up
um okay so I have a very interesting uh
situation so my husband and I live in a
duplex um that we purchased about six
years ago we live on the top unit and we
have tenants in the bottom unit
um we have two children
um we're sharing one car right now
that's being leased
um and so we're about 53 000 in Consumer
Debt and we have
um we owe about 180 K on the home and so
um the home is not in the greatest
neighborhood like I said we have two
children so we're kind of outgrowing the
home as well and so um listen to your
show I told my husband I said that we
should you know sell the home and we
look to make about you know anywhere
from 100 to 150k on the profit of the
house and so we would be able to pay off
all of our debts we would have a fully
funded emergency fund um able to get rid
of the lease and purchase two cars which
we really need
um cash and then also have a down
payment on future homes so it does a lot
and so um he's convinced that we should
keep the home and I kind of feel like
he's kind of gambling uh potential
future he feels like it's his unicorn of
investment and after you know x amount
of years he's going to have like this
big payoff and so I've done like two
Financial models to show him like you
know how even if we keep it and then
rent somewhere else that we're
struggling like we're really tight you
know with our budget which doesn't mean
any room for like paying down the debts
or saving for emergency let alone for
the children's future or retirement so
my question is like what can I show him
or do to help him understand
um the necessity to sell the home and
not keep it for a potential payoff later
wow you laid that out beautifully and uh
if you've already tried Financial models
I don't know what's going to convince
this guy other than being his wife and
just sitting him down and being like I'm
scared
I'm not sleeping well we don't have an
emergency fund we're 53 000 in debt
we're in a dangerous neighborhood trying
to raise these two kids and I want
better for us and selling this house
would give us a clean slate next week
and we'll be back we'll be investing in
the future in no time but right now we
got to clean up this mess have you just
sat him down and did that instead of
showing excel's spreadsheets yes I have
I started with that I started with high
emotion you know messing me back out of
it let me see numbers for myself and I
got all the numbers and I've been
reading and looking to educate myself to
make sure that I wasn't missing anything
and I've showed them the models as well
and he still believes that you know we
should move out but that we should keep
it as a rental as we're renting and I
just told them that our liability so he
wants to get broker by keeping the
mortgage and then getting another
mortgage on top of the Consumer Debt
while having no savings
well he was we would rent next year for
two years and then get a mortgage after
yes we would eventually have two
mortgages on top of yeah rent plus a
mortgage is not fun yeah he's going to
be getting an increase in Pay soon um
and so he thinks that I'm making more
money so I'm saying I'm telling like the
money can't go out with the expenses but
that we're basically in the same
position that if we increase our income
or we have less expenses and we have all
this extra money to now put towards that
I'm going to put towards retirement and
savings and things like that
um so I'm just having a hard time
getting through to him also part of that
is he's an architect by trade and he
recently got into real estate
development so I think because he's in
development now he's like looking at all
the numbers and all the potentials and
he's like he was entrepreneurial and he
wants to like he wants us to be you know
extremely wealthy and I appreciate that
but I think he wants to put the people
before the egg and he wants to just jump
into this thing and hold on to what he's
afraid of losing as he said our only
asset well I think there's something
bigger than this name I I appreciate you
wanting to defend him and think that hey
he's he's doing all these cool things
with his new job and this that that must
be what it is he's looking at all these
numbers
um I don't think that's it at all
I think he is around some guys that are
ahead of him
um financially and they've got some
rental properties I think he watches too
much YouTube and watches too much
Instagram or Tick Tock and I think he
hears all these dudes flexing about real
estate real estate real estate and he's
over here with the least car
one car and it's like he can't even see
the forest for the trees right
um it's that guy that like hasn't been
to the gym in years but just keeps
putting on tighter shirts because he
feels big inside of them right it's it's
just a strange Flex that's not working I
don't think this has anything to do with
him getting sophisticated or Smarter
with numbers I think it sounds like a
guy who's getting more and more scared
because math doesn't care what you want
math is just math and he's got I'll tell
you this is also scary he has a
brilliant
very clear thinking wife
because you've been through all the
numbers you've been through all the
emotions you've been through all the
tracks the the I mean you've done it all
um I I honestly would go back to what
George said that I would do it not in
your home okay I know that sounds weird
but I would take him somewhere
there's something about our homes or
something about places that are familiar
that our brains automates a lot of
things
and sometimes it makes it hard to hear
or hard to learn or hard to see a
different perspective because everything
just gets dumped into a think of it like
a highway that's familiar when you're at
in a road that you've never been on
before every one of your senses is up
and alert where are we what safe where
are we going and so taking them out for
breakfast somewhere y'all getting away
for a weekend and just going to a nice
hotel somewhere whatever
take them away and say I want to plan
for the future for real and I want you
to start that conversation with I'm so
scared I can't breathe
good y'all I know I know I know I feel
like he needs something as I'm like I'm
looking forward like is there another
piece of data no this is not a data
issue
this is not a math problem you could
have a 400 page spreadsheet and all the
data in the world and he's still going
to be like this is a grown man this is a
grown man with an ego problem this is
not a matter I mean we called it a
unicorn acid it could be a unicorn asset
like a duplex in Detroit in a bad
neighborhood is a unicorn of an asset
that's is he listening to himself also
we put a lot into we purchased it it was
like you know complete the labrador we
put all this energy we model it I mean
and it turned out great and the
neighborhood is up and coming but it's
slow it and actually in six years it
hasn't moved as fast as we thought and
so you know we do have profit in it
which is great but it's like it's still
it's just not I don't know the Unicorn
part he said that that's quote Unicorn
oh it sounds like something he would say
but like John said at the root of this
is not a guy who's super smart it's a
guy who there's three things going on
here there's Pride fear and greed and
maybe a little bit of all of it and that
doesn't mean he's a bad person it just
means he's gotten starry-eyed about how
smart he is and how he's the exception
to the rule and how he's going to become
the next rich guy and one day you're
going to thank him for doing this risky
thing but right now you're scared and
you want what's best for your family
there's also a number four detached from
reality
mm-hmm right if he if he found a hundred
thousand dollar property in downtown
Nashville
and said honey we'd see to hold us for a
second I've got a unicorn I would go
yeah you're right he did because
national properties are insane
a dilapidated refurbed duplex
you are it's a hippopotamus it is not a
uh not a unicorn and what happens when
you guys move out and the tenants trash
the place and then the hvac's broken and
you still have a lease car and fifty
thousand dollars in debt while paying
rent while needing to pay the mortgage
and the tenants stop paying on top of
that has he thought about that as a
possibility I think because we've had
really good tenants in six years we've
never had a missed payment like we've
done great with that I think that he
thinks that that's going to be even more
like mobile and then like they're going
to keep paying on time and we haven't
had any major expenses but we're hitting
over the six year mark now so that means
the house they're going to start doing
some stuff it was built in 1900 I
believe in 1901. this is a guy that has
had one rental house one experience
George and I get to sit by Dave who's
got a whole whole bunch of rental
properties people don't pay if you watch
the news and watch what happened with
covet people just quit paying their rent
so much so that that uh politicians had
to pass the laws that so you couldn't
kick them out of their house because
people just quit paying they couldn't
pay they didn't have any jobs they
weren't allowed to go to work right
yeah I wish there was a math problem I
wish there was a oh yeah just say this
but you've got a husband like those
three things George is talking about you
got a husband's detached from reality
and that has this grandiose vision of
himself and his smarts in his universe
that is simply not true the only way I
know through that is emotions
foreign
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George
Campbell listen if you're a new listener
and you want to dive deeper into the
Ramsay baby steps
or you're wondering what are y'all
talking about when you even say baby
steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button
so many people are like all right I'm
all in I'm all in I don't even know
where to start we're going to help you
figure out the best next step for your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you are right now and very personalized
this is for you go to
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started we'll get you going
so John this was a great tweet from our
friend Dave Ramsey the other day he said
I remember standing in the grocery store
one day when Sharon and I were flat
broke I wrote a check for food and
immediately got this sick feeling in the
pit of my stomach wondering if I had
just spent the money that we needed to
pay the electric bill
and so what Dave's getting at here is
this thing we talk about on the show
this I've had it moment where you go
that was it everyone has that thing or
they point back to and go that's when I
realized this is a problem worth solving
what was yours mine was when I
experienced identity theft and I knew
that identity theft is for Real Jim it's
it's a real thing so I pulled my credit
reports and the scarier part was not the
identity theft of these accounts people
opened it was the accounts that I opened
for all these student loans and I had
never actually looked at the numbers I
just knew like well we'll get student
loans and eventually I'll have to deal
with them I had it up exactly what I
owed and all these student loans and it
took my breath away
and then I realized my first job out of
college it was barely enough to pay rent
the student loan minimum payments
because you actually have to pay those
back once you graduate all of my utility
bills and I was like this is the path
that I was sold this is it and that is
when I was like this something's got to
give because this sucks this life is
terrible and I was super cynical towards
adulthood toward all the lies that
people had told me and then I realized
oh okay it's not all my fault but it's
my responsibility to do what's next and
so we actually pulled the baby steps
group uh do you have any that you
remember
man I I remember it was during 2008 2009
when the financial crisis hit and I was
um working at a fancy University and
um man I was reading all of this data in
higher education about all these schools
that were super debt leveraged and that
pushed me over into some other
literature about how these businesses
were debt leveraged and now when the
credit markets were frozen that they
couldn't operate and eat and I was found
myself thinking what idiots would have
this much business Revenue but owe this
much money what kind of idiots would do
that oh God that's me right like we owe
this much money as like six figures two
loans we had thous so much we owed so
much money and I remember having a like
a multi-year panic attack that just
never stopped for a long time because I
realized oh I'm as leveraged as them but
I don't have a government that's going
to bail me out right my family and I
just lose our house and I had a new
toddler so there was this there was a
terrifying moment that as I was watching
these businesses fail and these big
Banks fail I just could see the see the
writing on the wall like oh you're next
your family's next this intellectual
exercise became an emotional mirror for
you where you went like oh this isn't
just like news headlines I'm living this
this is me I make this much money and I
have borrowed this this much money
that's good well we pulled the baby
steps Facebook group over 400 000 folks
in there and uh here's just some
interesting ones that I think May uh
Inspire some folks out there to either
have their own or decide I've had it one
person said I was changing my daughter
getting her ready for bed her pajamas
were too small and I had just used my
last few dollars to buy formula didn't
me Dave until later but I started then
to live without debt wow that's a
wake-up call
that'd be so scary like I can't afford
clothes that fit this child
because of how leveraged I am here's
another one after Christmas in 2019 I
sat down to pay the bills and just got
so annoyed that we were always a step
behind I literally said to my husband we
make too much to be this broke that is
the quote that tells me you're ready
until you say that out loud you're not
ready another one when I had to take
money out of my child's savings to pay
bills it was the first quote debt I paid
in baby step two that's a sobering
moment when the first item on your dead
snowball is putting the money back that
you stole from your child
oh my goodness that's that's a move that
keeps you up at night right yeah when my
husband had to save emergency had to
have emergency surgery and I couldn't be
with him because we were in so much debt
oh my God I couldn't miss the couldn't
miss the hours at work yeah wow
wow when my card declined a day before
payday at the McDonald's drive-through
all I wanted was 2.99 fries for my
daughter I became so bitter with living
paycheck to paycheck and didn't sleep
that night that's how I found Dave on
YouTube fast forward to six months now
and I went from baby step zero to baby
step six I work like a horse never again
so I I think this isn't a gosh this is
so important and this is the thing that
gets this show in hot water all the time
has for years
you can have a never again moment and
just go on a blaming raged out tirade
it's their fault if they hadn't if if
this hadn't happened to me
it did
and it's it's worth tears and it's
heartbreaking and it's often
generational
but the question we all have to ask
ourselves is is well now what and these
people who are you are reading I think
it's so beautiful they had these moments
and then they said there is no there's
no Cavalry coming this is me me and my
house we have to fix this and so I'm
going to take this bull by the horns I'm
going to wrestle to the ground and I'm
gonna do whatever I have to do and
there's a sense of what this show has
always been about which is empowerment
it is that you can get back in the
driver's seat of your car if you realize
hey we're about to die and because your
car's careening off the road and you
just stay in the back seat and yell ah
you're still going to go off the edge
right if the only chance you got is to
get back in that driver's seat and try
to steer it to safety that's a great
analogy I'm picturing the passenger and
the oh crap but holding the oh crap bar
going oh my gosh what do we do and they
realize like oh no one's in I can step
into the driveway and drive I can
control this vehicle but it's hard to
get to that moment and the good news is
you don't have to get to this like Rock
Bottom terrifying moment you can just
decide that average sucks and that you
can do better than that but it takes a
step forward where you go my plan isn't
working I'm a financial genius who's
broke let me try a different plan and
that's what I did back in 2013 I was
like this ain't cutting it so I went
through Financial Peace University and I
was like oh this is a paradigm shift
this is jarring this is offensive
because everything I was told all these
myths that I believe that led me here
were a lie so you're kind of mad at Dave
at first and you're like oh he's not the
problem he's just the guy on the corner
being like there's a different way you
got screwed and when you can get over
that piece life change can happen
yeah every single every single time man
um where should they go if so if someone
just heard that and they're like I'm
having that I had that moment last night
I went to get my kids uh clothes for
school
my son grew seven inches over the hall
over the summer break and I can't afford
jeans like I'm tired of this uh where do
they go man well there's a few steps you
can take number one paying attention to
your money while the scariest step is
the most crucial and so I always tell
people jump onto every dollar create a
free budget and just lay out a plan and
just go oh okay we make this much money
here's all of our expenses and that at
least tells you are we in the hole or do
we have plenty of margin and we're just
wasting it so that really is one of the
most crucial things just putting a plan
to paper that's just choosing reality
we're just choosing reality yeah and
list out all of your debts some of you
need to figure out how much debt you
actually have because you've had your
head buried in the sand not wanting to
look at it because it's too gross and
the other thing you can do is get new
information
one of those is listening to the show
right now people say I listen to the
show I get motivated either you go I'm
not as bad as that person right that's
half the people listen to the show or
you go that person was me or that person
could be me so you start dreaming out
loud you go through Financial Peace
University and you sit there and watch
all nine lessons and you're like I know
too much to go back ignorance was Bliss
and not anymore because I know too much
I know that these are all traps meant to
hold me back meant to hold back my
future and uh you know people like to be
like that whole Dave Ramsey place man
they're like a cult telling people to
cut up their credit cards I'm like or
are you the brainwashed one who believes
that this is the path and here's what's
strange uh this is before I worked here
this is since I've worked here
I um I I had knee surgery a few years
ago and I heard people say oh that guy
is the best surgeon ever I heard people
say I'll never have that guy do do my
knee surgery right so I had to dig in
meet with him and all that I've never
met one person before working here after
that said you know I wish I hadn't paid
all that debt off I wish I hadn't done
that huge regret I wish I'd just go on
vacations instead of paying off I've
never heard it why because it's always
worth it freedom is always worth it hey
that's the first hour in the books thank
you for joining us America we'll be back
soon right here on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey Show a show about your money your
work your emotional mental health your
life I'm John deloney joined with my
good friend George Campbell and we are
taking your calls on just about anything
AAA
[Music]
825-52258-825-5225 you got stuff going
on in your marriage you got stuff going
on in your budget you got got Financial
questions you got questions about
raising kids whatever you got we're here
to help triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go out to Selena in
Dover what's up Selena how are we doing
okay guys can you hear me we can how in
the world already
I'm 27 years old no I said how in the
world are you
oh how in the world am I I'm all right
I'm all right I can't complain though
you know I'm grateful good
um so basically my back story is um you
know I had everything together and a few
years ago a friend and I oh I called our
friend we're not friends anymore we got
the bright idea to try drugs and I
pretty much lost everything I lost my
home I was evicted from my home I
crashed my car
I have so many collections I have about
twenty seven thousand dollars in
collections I have 16 000 in student
loans and I have a 28 000
repossession of the car I that's now
charged off that I crashed I was on a
run
and I have three boys one of them has
autism he's actually sitting here with
me
um four years ago we lost his father on
his third birthday his father passed
away from an overdose
um my husband and I are our marriage
recently has been kind of hanging on by
thread and it's mainly got finances it's
the main thing because my husband's
wages are now being garnished for things
that I caused
so it's it's been rough his family
doesn't really talk to me anymore so
we're just trying to rebuild her
Financial Health and our marriage and
just kind of figure out where to where
to go right now the only income I get is
[Music]
um the money I get from my son's father
passing away and I stay in sober living
right now with my two children and I
have three boys total which the
unfortunate part about cerebral living
is you can only have two children with
you so my three-year-old stays with his
father
so that's that's been hard what I want
is to be able to obtain a home somehow
whether I rent get a mortgage
and just have my family back together
and pay off the stud and be free
financially and never never look back
again I want you to write those goals
down and more importantly I want you to
draw those a picture of those goals
the Hipster cool thing to do is to write
down goals I think it has value to it
um
but for somebody who's traveled the path
you've traveled you're probably very
good with words with getting in and out
of situations you're good at talking
yeah what is challenging is to a trust
and believe things and B actually
picture them something different
and so what you just said about a home
that it's yours I want you to draw it
out even if it's just you and crayons
and construction paper and I want you to
put it somewhere where you can see it
because right now your number one goal
is stay sober
there is being a connected mom um being
a homeowner having a great marriage all
of that
comes after stay clean because you can't
do any of those things if you're using
absolutely and so the goal here is I
want to stay in sober living as long as
I need to I'm going to work
as best as much as I can
and I will
care and love my kids and I will also
reach out and get help for these boys I
would it's going to sound
counterintuitive I would rather your
boys be with somebody for six months
that's not you and you spend those six
months being completely clean completely
well completely whole
then go in and go out and go in and go
out and go in and go out over the next
three or four years okay
and I also don't want you using those
boys as a teddy bear
yeah you know what I mean it's not their
job to prop up Mom in this season
yeah absolutely you're right and so um
are you clean now
yes probably six months in a couple days
how long
six months in a few days yeah dude way
to go man
did you have a big celebration a big six
month yeah I'm I'm done I just I can't
do it anymore I I came to a head back in
November
um I tried to take myself out of this
world I was pregnant and um and I went
to rehab and I decided I was done that
my children deserved better but more
importantly I had to learn to love
myself because you know you can't pour
from an empty cup I have to I have to
show my children that mom loves herself
enough to show that I can do this so
that is beautiful
um
inpatient language do you believe that
I do I do and it's it's it's I have to
remind myself some days and and you know
some days are hard
because everything just seems to be kind
of hitting me because
um I've got some of my wages they're
trying to garnish some of my wages too
and you know it just seems some days it
seems like it's too much but
at the end of the day I have to remember
to be grateful that I have my life
I don't know that there's going to be a
too much for you you've seen too much
you're too strong you've been through
too much you've stared hell down in the
face and you accepted help and you walk
back and so those people calling you
saying we're gonna you can just smile at
him and say all right that's cute kind
of like a like a middle schooler talking
trash to a UFC fighter like oh that's
that's cute uh I'm tougher than yeah
right you've been there that's an
understatement it's just I mean my my
story goes all the way back to my
childhood I of course abusive childhood
my parents were addicts um I went home
to home every several months so you know
I'd never had stability in my life
had his hands on my life all my life so
I mean I've come a very long way you
absolutely and here's what you're gonna
do you're going to create the home
um you're gonna create the home that you
didn't have yes you're gonna be the mom
that you didn't have your kids exactly
are going to have a different Legacy
this is called changing your family tree
um how can I help you right now what's
the thing that George and I can do to
help you right now
I just want to make the right step to
for my Financial Health I want to be
able to save money I want to be able to
start working on my debt
the right way and still have money put
back I want to work on the baby step one
to have a thousand dollars without
tapping into it because that seems to be
a problem
um we're downsizing our storage units to
a cheaper one it's going to cut the cost
in half what's in the storage unit that
you need our our home pretty much
everything yeah when are you going to be
able to get full-time income
in the next couple weeks
because
um I'm trying to relocate down the state
where I'm at so I can have more help
with child care from my family and stuff
so Selena I want you all these plans
these plans these plans I want you to
write them on a piece of paper get them
out of your head okay
because they come at you like fireworks
right yes they do all right so I want
you to write these things down here's
plan one plan two Plan Three I want you
to get somebody in your sober living
community that will be accountability
for you probably
um a sponsor of some sort and somebody
walking alongside you I don't want you
to hang on the line I'm gonna send you
own your past and change your future and
my brand new book building an on anxious
life and I'm gonna send you Financial
Peace University and I'm missing you a
year of every dollar all of it I'm gonna
give you all the tools to get you
launched out
but you have to go make it happen we
love you you call us anytime and we're
here to help you I'm so so so proud of
you so proud of you we'll be right back
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm John
deloney joined by George Campbell triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're taking your calls on money
marriage life mental health emotional
health all of it
the Ramsey Show question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
home services from repairs and
maintenance to Remodeling and upgrades
neighborly's trusted Home Service
provide providers have trained local
experts who can handle almost any job so
go to neighborly.com the find and
schedule service today today's question
comes from Cindy in New Mexico within
the last week I found out that not one
but two close friends who make over a
hundred thousand dollars which is very
good for our part of the country are so
deep in debt they are considering filing
for bankruptcy I'm honestly floored I
would love to talk to them about the
Ramsay way but not entirely sure how to
gently broach the topic I know they will
ultimately make their own decision but I
also want to show them there's another
way
oh this is a lot less financial and a
lot more uh relational and uh gently
broach the topic if my buddy's on the
brink of bankruptcy I don't think
there's anything gentle about what's
going on here I think I'm gonna shake
them and go dude please do not do this
there's another way and I don't know
they're going to listen to you at that
point yeah I I'm a big believer in
staying out of people's business unless
they're about to get hit by a truck
and so for instance if if I'm with my
friends and they're like yeah we've
decided to stop going to doctors we just
um we got a special herb out in our yard
and we rub it on our first YouTube video
Yeah diarrhea then you know what if you
don't if you ask me like do you think
that's a good idea oh I'm gonna tell you
but they don't they don't ask me that
and so I smile and say I can't wait to
hear how that works out
but if they said hey uh we have a
toddler and we've been growing this
three uh leaved plant that some call
Poison Ivy we're gonna rub it all over
their face to help with their eczema I
would yell and it's kick and scream
right so in this case if your friends
are throwing credit cards down on the
table at dinner all the time and they're
always talking about what a great deal
they got on their new lease
I don't get involved in those
conversations because they didn't ask my
opinion
but if I have a friend who's about to
file bankruptcy they make a whole bunch
of money
um and they just don't understand
because you and I both talk to people
who have filed for bankruptcy and it is
a traumatic event I'm gonna get involved
because I love my friends and say I
can't I have to I have to speak now
because I can't forever hold my peace
don't do this right if there's another
way let's figure this thing I would go
and I'd say hey drinks on me I'm gonna
buy you dinner here's what I'm asking
before you file for bankruptcy just read
this book Total Money Makeover and say
just read it and let's have a
conversation I'm gonna send you four
YouTube clips that's gonna be a total of
like 40 minutes watch those and then um
that's it that's how many questions
let's talk and if you decide after that
you're gonna do what you want that's
fine but at least read this book takes
six hours and do this one thing before
you implode your financial life and not
only employ your financial slate you're
going to strain your marriage the
chances of you hanging on your marriage
go away the chances of you hanging onto
your physical health go away your
emotions go away so um let's do whatever
we can and this is just me loving you
like I know how to do and if you tell me
to shut my mouth in my own business
that's fair yeah but I needed to tell
you I think a truck's coming right at
you and that tone matters it's not from
a high horse of like wow you're so
financially unsophisticated it's dude I
love you I don't want to see you go
through this I know what happens when
people go through this I know you know
what happens but this is not the only
option you're showing them option C and
doing it in a way that is not
gentle and hey what if no this is dude
do not drive off the cliff please if a
car is coming towards a little kid in
the road you don't go
um we don't want to scare him so um hey
Billy Billy there's a car coming no you
scream at the top of your lungs right
and you go running and screaming you
might even shove a kid out of the way to
keep him from getting run over right
yeah that's this kind of situation here
right that's tough though not an easy
situation to deal with not trying to
minimize it but I'll say this Sydney
thanks for being a friend that cares
thanks for being a friend that cares uh
most friends just go oh my gosh YOLO the
theme of today's episode is you can't
change other people yeah every single
call has been like I really wanna you
can't yeah you can't make them do
anything they don't want to do they're
adults yeah and that's a really hard
thing to grieve just to go like I knew
there was a better answer a better way
and they did the dumb thing and they
don't didn't ask me or they did and they
did something completely different and
that people have the right to
make decisions that's America Freedom
goes both ways let's go out to
Minneapolis and talk to the great and
wonderful Matt hey Matt what's up
hey how you guys doing today we're doing
great man
Hey so uh real quick I've been following
the Ramsey Baby Steps um I just
graduated college a few months ago got a
full-time job and I'm wondering about
how I go about saving for a house while
investing
um I don't have any debt I went through
college I paid off all my school uh so
I'm debt free now I'm living at home
hopefully only for a year or so before
getting in the apartment or something
um yeah just kind of wondering what you
guys thoughts were on money management
while I save up that's awesome okay so
what are you making
um I started at 26 an hour and there's
quite a bit of overtime left so I've
been eating quite a bit of that up and
then I work part-time at a restaurant
sweets we're talking 60k Plus
yeah hopefully awesome okay and you have
an emergency fund saved up I know you
don't have a ton of expenses right now
living at home but what do you have in
savings
yeah so
um I've got it all written down here I
have a Roth IRA with about 1200 in it
the emergency fund is in a high yield
savings with about two grand and then I
have another separate savings account
with about seven Grand and then I have a
normal taxable brokerage account with
about three grand in it okay so you're
already on this path of investing and
you've got about 9 000 liquid does that
sound right
correct okay so that's that would put
you in baby step three B which is where
you save up for the down payment for a
home and while you live at home I mean
take advantage of that live on nothing
and there's a few paths for this it's a
Choose Your Own Adventure when you get
to when it comes to investing in down
payment in this phase some people do
zero percent and they go hard on that
down payment some people choose to do 15
and then whatever's left throw at the
down payment some people do the match
and then beyond that throw money at the
down payment my favorite version is
let's invest 50 clearly you love
investing and so if you're able to make
up the Gap and still hit your down
payment goal while investing fifteen
percent all the better but if you told
me hey I want to pause because this is a
huge goal for me and in one year I want
to buy this house then I would say all
right well let's pause investing and so
you just kind of pull the lever in
whatever Direction you're feeling and at
your age you have tons of time to invest
so it does not worry me for you to go to
zero percent for a period of time
how does that hit you what are you
feeling
yeah I was just
um for this first year of living at home
I was thinking about renting after
moving out before you know getting a
house because uh you know come to think
of it there's a lot more expenses than
just the house payment oh 100 and not
only that but you've got the earnest
money you've got the closing costs you
have the down payment you have if
there's any fixes the house needs you
have ongoing maintenance and repairs
property taxes homeowners insurance it's
not all gum drops and rainbows once
you're a homeowner and I love
homeownership but I think it's a good
warning to those who feel like renting
is a sin and it's a waste of money and
I'm going dude renting is the most
you're going to pay right now the
mortgages is the the bottom of the
barrel before we start adding on the
other expenses so I think it's wise at
your age just go rent for a year
whether you do that now or a year from
now yeah and that that's the highest the
highest form of advice I could give you
is if you were my little brother if you
were my my best friend's son I would
tell you the exact same thing I think a
year of practicing living on your own
renting paying bills figuring out how
that works when the when the cable
company says they're going to be there
that's probably the oldest thing I've
ever said when the internet company says
they're going to be there
um and they don't show up like dealing
with all that stuff and that's a good
bridge to what comes next and you and
your analytical investing mind are gonna
think you're a waste of money it's gonna
feel like I could have been I could be
making so much more if I wasn't paying
rent
that's part of growing up is dealing
with some of those feelings and knowing
no I'm doing the right thing right I
feel this but I'm gonna go ahead and do
the next right thing anyway
but you're crushing it man just stay on
this path don't you like living at home
by the way
what's that do you like living at home
by the way is that working for you
yeah I do I've I've been blessed with
that with having some parents that take
good care of me and they allow me to
live their rent free so I'm taking
advantage of that while I can but I'm
trying to stay thankful it's awesome how
old are you
I just turned 21. oh my gosh so can you
imagine John if we were 21 thinking like
him oh yeah no I definitely was not
doing that I'm gonna say give you some
just my opinion on it's going to sound a
little bit counterintuitive than what we
normally would say on this show
um it sounds like you have a good head
on your shoulders which makes me think
your folks had a good head on their
shoulders as well you all have a great
relationship I might not Sprint out of
this house
um if it's working for y'all in this
season you do need to get out and get
your own place
um but man if you can leave with a pile
of cash and your relationship with your
parents is still intact man you may want
to hang on to this for another six
months or another year um if it's
working for everybody just a thought
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
back
[Music]
thank you
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
George I was just telling my wife the
other day it feels Criminal
that the kids already go back to school
it confuses me I grew up in the north
you didn't go to school until after
Labor Day in this side I'm like it's
July May 25th School you were out and
you went back after
Christmas I don't know it just felt like
what happened to kids enjoying their
youth enjoying the summer we don't have
time for that George any other countries
are coming for us well poor teachers
didn't get to enjoy their summer because
they're back teaching that's exactly
right teachers and students across the
country are headed back to the classroom
and to honor the heroes that we call
teachers we have one of our great
foundations and personal finance
teachers on the show with us it is The
Great and Wonderful Greg from Green Bay
Wisconsin what's up Greg
hey guys how you doing today I'm excited
to be with you thank you for having me
on the show rocking on to the break of
dawn man we are honored to talk to you
my friend so where do you teach and how
many students go there
I teach at a schwabenon high school
which is a suburb of Green Bay and we
have right around uh between a thousand
and Eleven Hundred students that's a
party how long have you been teaching
um for 15 years wow so you're that's a
thousand years old in in human years
am I in office like did you start and
you were just bright-eyed bushy Tails
all your hair
yeah I'm a little gray and sitting on
top so like you're doing good work
you're doing good work so we understand
that you do a lot of work with your
students on how they can go to college
without taking student loans what does
that look like and do you have any
stories that come to mind as you've been
kind of coaching these kids
five foundations are awesome we go
through all of them but when I get to
the cash for college and talking about
college I'm amazed at how many kids are
setting off to college and I pose one
question to them and I ask them I say uh
how are you going to pay for college and
almost every one of the students say I'm
going to take on a loan so I repeat the
question I say no how are you going to
pay for college and the response again
is with confusion because you know just
the standard is this is how the system
works we're gonna go to college we're
going to take out loans and we'll pay
for them later
so I really break it down and dive into
what they're actually paying for because
when they become 18 or these responsible
adults the debt they take on becomes
theirs so I really try to uh you know
show them the impact and break down how
that debt will actually impact them over
the next 10 15 20 or possibly their
entire lifetime wow when did you get
inspired to take this on because I've
been a public school teacher and there's
some pretty tight parameters about what
we talk about and when we talk about it
and all that what inspired you to say
I'm going to stop the presses because
these kids got to know this
buy what their parents mistakes have
done and things like that it's like wait
a minute you write your own financial
future we're going to start turning this
around and showing kids who are you know
a lot of kids don't see their value or
their worth because uh when your
financial Outlook from the past has been
full of Doom and Gloom they don't see
how they can get out of the hole so this
is something that I teach business and
marketing and I came from a business
background so it was like we need to get
this in the hands of the kids uh you
know and everybody should have this
financial understanding and financial
literacy because we can make all the
money we want but if we can't handle it
it doesn't make any sense
so I took it on about about nine years
ago I really started hammering the
personal finance really hard and five
years ago uh through my son and
daughter-in-law discovered you know the
Ramsey practices and then right away
said my kids need this wow that's
amazing that's incredible I can't wait
to hear the stories as kids go to
college graduate and they reach back out
like Mr Greg dude I'm working now I got
no debt like oh my gosh like the ripple
effect you're having and how
instrumental you are in these kids
financial future even more than their
parents who are just don't have a plan
and going I guess we'll take out that
I'll co-sign and you're out here
coaching these kids one-on-one showing
them a different path and for that we
are so grateful for you Greg
yeah thank you I appreciate it there's
so many opportunities to do this when
you break it down you know I pose a real
quick question to the kids I say how
many you would take on a loan for your
food then pay interest on it over the
next 10 to 15 years
and of course every student goes well
that's stupid why would we do that and I
said then why will 80 of you are going
to a four-year College do that because
half of half of your money goes to
housing and food
so that's you know on average about nine
grand a year here in our state
so it's like you are going to pay for
that until you're in your 30s that's an
interesting way to think about it your
room and board for that cafeteria you're
paying six percent interest on for the
next 20 years
correct oh my God let me say this
um on behalf of myself I got a middle
schooler and a seven-year-old little
girl and George is a is a soon father to
be
like
um it's real easy to get down at how the
world looks you know when you spend too
much time in the in in the media and
when you're watching the news
and it's
guys like you
it's men and women like you who are out
there
um saying that on my watch and I know
I've got a curriculum to cover but I'm
gonna make sure that these young men and
women before they leave are School you
are the guys are gonna and Are Gonna
Change
our culture you're the guys are going to
give they give hope and light new fires
with these youngsters and it's amazing
to learn more about the foundations and
personal finance course and how you can
bring it to your high school if you're
one of those teachers or you know a
teacher who's constantly coming home
saying oh my gosh I've got to teach
these kids something else
um or if you're a teacher saying what I
just can't sleep anymore knowing that
these kids are just jumping off the
cliff and jumping off the cliff and
jumping off the cliff without the right
information go to ramseysolutions.com
education and if you think I'm just a
homeschool parent I just we have a
program for you to go to
ramseysolutions.com slash education and
if you don't have an incredible teacher
like Greg to help you find a way to go
to college debt free and you're stuck
with student loans be sure to go to
ramseysolutions.com student loans to get
that stuff out of your life forever
forever uh George did you have a teacher
that was super inspirational to you 100
senior year here Dr lefla my English
teacher I was in English AP I'm not
smart I'm not even great reading agreed
but I was in it because he was like you
have a gift of creative writing you're a
musician writing lyrics I want you in my
class and I want you to develop this
skill and to this day I mean I just I'm
finishing edits on my first book and I'm
like I'm he's in the back of my mind
going this is the guy who said you can
do this you have you have what it takes
and so teachers are so instrumental in
your future more than they even know and
the ripple effect they have is inspiring
and Greg is doing that right now that's
incredible man all right let's run out
real quick to Detroit and talk to
Michael hey Michael what's up
hey guys it is a pleasure to talk to you
thanks for taking my call I really
appreciate it you bet him up against the
clock so hop right to your question all
right
hey hey I'm an everyday millionaire I
just made it last month congratulations
yeah thank you and I've got like 200 000
in cash and I'm I'm just wondering what
should I do with that whatever you want
you're welcome to mail it to us up here
man I'm happy to now congratulations man
so do you have a paid for a house thank
you are you homeowner
I have a paid for house and I just sold
a lake house that was a mistake
um but we got the money out of that lake
house and that's what pushed me over the
edge wow okay so you're sitting on 200
000 you have the emergency fund you have
a paid for house now is the time to
inflate the the tires here when it comes
to giving saving and spending and that's
a really nice way to balance it so you
don't get out of control so you don't
need to go invest all 200 000 let's give
some let's increase our lifestyle to a
certain degree if you want to do that if
it's time to upgrade the car I mean some
of these baby steps millionaires out
there they've been on a vacation in 10
years I'm like go on a freaking vacation
have some nice stuff you can do this now
you've lived like no one else and the
other side continue to build wealth and
invest and find things you're passionate
about get plugged in I mean you probably
have more time now too right
uh yeah because I don't have to take
care of the place up north yeah I do
have more time but I still work full
time I work a lot of overtime very cool
um I'm actually retired from one company
drawing a pension and working at a
second company and film investing in
another 401. so you've got options here
so that's what I'm trying to tell you is
Now's the Time To Dream a little bit and
go what could we do George I I would
love before you start spinning and
giving I'd love I love Michael if you
and a buddy or two went out and you all
dreamed about okay we've been running
our whole lives and now we're here
we get to we get to we get to decide
what the back half of this thing looks
like what do we want this thing to look
like who do we want to give to where do
we want to live what do we want to drive
where do we want to visit and let's
dream a little bit and then you can
reverse engineer that with those three
steps George just gave you and you are
Off to the Races congratulations good
man congrats
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
hey welcome back everybody this is the
Ramsey Show I'm John deloney joined by
George Campbell listen
um
if you are like me and you are concerned
about the financial direction of the
country
um all these student loan numbers and
credit card debt just passed a trillion
dollars and Mortgage Debt just this and
that
and you just want to go to your
neighbor's house and say what are you
doing but you can't do that because your
neighbor's kind of weird and you don't
know him listen
if you will go subscribe like this show
it is a way for no money
for you to help spread the message that
we're trying to to to to to to to
communicate here which is to empower
people to take control of their money
take control of their life and if
everybody will take care of their house
and their finances and stop owing people
money and stop living so unintentionally
and so recklessly with no margin if
people will take this on then the
problems in Washington
the whole conversation changes and I
know it's hard to go knock on your
neighbor's door and say hey I see those
two cars that you're leasing out there
you should read this book because
they'll tell you to leave but if you
will like or subscribe this show
um if you will leave a five-star review
if you hear a great great episode or a
great call you just text it to your
friend it kicks the show up in the
algorithm and it helps get the show to
more people right you are our voice out
in the marketplace we don't spend a
jillion dollars advertising we don't buy
stadiums we don't put up
um I don't know but we still don't do a
lot of that stuff because we have you
and people who are walking these baby
steps and their lives are changing
they're sleeping better their marriages
are improving their relationships with
their kids are changing they're able to
breathe again and you just can't help
but tell everybody when suddenly you
find yourself free so please leave a
review share it with your friends
subscribe do all the things on whatever
little Gadget you're listening to this
this show on it really makes a
difference for everybody thank you so so
much all right let's run out to uh let's
just walk down the street to Nashville
Tennessee and talk to our great friend
Rebecca what's up Rebecca
well I have a question I just applied
for a loan to get a third rental
property and the loan agent said that I
don't have
um enough debt for them to take a chance
to give me a rental property
yeah I love America
I am worth 1.5 million dollars
collectively with my husband my credit
score is like 780. they said that's not
true if you don't have debt you don't
have a credit score and she wants me to
go get some credit cards and some debt
before I reapply to purchase our third
home that the other two are outright
paid for I'm very confused okay so let
me get this straight you've got two paid
for properties you don't have debt but
you still have a credit score due to
some sort of open line of credit or you
have credit cards that you pay off every
month what's going on there um
like 200 000 on it so
um so I'm confused you said you're debt
free and she's saying you can't she's
saying that 200 000 mortgage isn't
enough debt to Warrant more debt well
it's in the 200 the the houses in both
of our name this one but that loan is in
my husband's name so I'm not on that
debt so technically that 200 000 is on
him got it and I have no debt so he
could take out the debt in his name the
property
yes he can take it out he's already got
it approved for him but I'm worried what
happens if he dies and I'm now trying to
I mean I know I have 1.5 in basically
real estate that I can buy a house for
cash so I'm still just nervous about me
not being able to get a loan like that
doesn't make sense to me
why do I have to so your fear is not at
his death it's I won't be able to get a
loan if he does die okay well let's
rewind here because here's here's my
thing we wouldn't even recommend you do
this rental property thing with debt I
would say you guys make plenty of money
you have an amazing net worth you've
built wealth let's just purchase this
when we have the cash
so that's my caveat is that I don't even
agree with this decision before we get
to why you can't get along with that
credit score I'm not a loan agent I
can't tell you why they won't give
someone with a 780 credit score alone I
thought you were saying you don't have a
credit score and therefore they wouldn't
give you a loan you have a 780 and
they're saying we won't do it
so that's because rental property is not
treated the same way as a primary
residence rental property is investment
and investment equals more risk to the
lender and so they see someone out here
you know floating a few properties a few
mortgages and they can just decide to
not give you the money if they don't
want to
okay so if he wants to take out the debt
and that's y'all's business I I don't
condone it but if he wanted to do it
under his name uh do you not have life
insurance either of you yes yeah we both
have
um well the hospital gives us like two
and a half times our our annual pay so
we have quite a bit of um you need 10x
each
yeah so our caller friends it's Xander
insurance and get 10x each on a term
life level term life policy is what
you're wanting uh how old are you two
um
okay look into it it may be a little
pricier but you guys have the money to
do it and clearly this is a fear of
yours if he dies what am I going to do
financially even though we have all
these assets I'm gonna have to liquidate
it all it could be a mess and two and a
half times income isn't going to get you
that far it will get you nowhere yeah
you're gonna need like millions in order
to survive this thing and grieve his
loss and go get more debt if that's what
you want to do but the other thing is
this again with the caveat I absolutely
think George is right don't borrow money
for a third rental property I'll make
way too much money save it up and buy it
it sounds like you want to do it because
you want one that's yours
Oh no just to build wealth because we
we're almost done paying this one off we
put about 18 000 a month on the current
home that just has the 200 000 left so
the other ones paid off this one will be
paid off relatively fast with 18 000 a
month so we're trying to look towards
this future of once this one's paid off
just buying a house every five years or
even less could you do that with cash
buy one every two years buy a four or
five hundred thousand dollar house every
two years just keep that same twenty
thousand dollars that you're paying on
your place and rolling it in
okay 20 grand times 12. you're talking
240 times two years you have 480 every
two years to go buy more property and
when you do it that way it's gonna cash
flow like it's because the houses start
paying for themselves so then you take
all the income from your houses and you
buy another one and then you buy another
one and then yes and that's where we did
our first one yep let's keep that going
so let's just focus on this mortgage you
have right now your house off pay it off
then let's do cash for the rest of them
and I that's not a pie in the sky that
is how Dave Ramsey has purchased many
many properties uh over the last 30
years now
okay after he got burned doing it the
risky way of like well we're just going
to keep collecting more debt and the
tenants will pay for it so it's
basically free money it's a money making
scheme until it's not yeah and you said
it best I want to build wealth hang on
the line I'm gonna send you Dave's book
his most recent bestseller baby steps
Millionaires and it really is a map it's
a road map that says hey the world and
Instagram and Tick Tock are going to
tell you to get rich this way here's the
way to do it all the other speculative
nonsense yes people have gotten wealthy
because they happen to be doing
something risky in a sliver of History
where it worked out there's also people
who go to Vegas and you hear about them
a friend's cousins Grandma's brother who
made a whole bunch of money Vegas
wouldn't exist if that happened every
time that's why you know about that one
guy similarly speculative real estate
rolls over and rolls over and rolls over
but if you have four houses five houses
six houses that you own in cash and then
you get one of these these real estate
rollover covers then you just go knock
on your neighbor's door and say hey I'll
buy that for half its value in cash
right now and that's how people pick up
a lot of houses when things get sideways
they don't owe anybody any money and
they got cash from that cash flow it's a
different game that's Building Wealth
it's Chestnut Checkers getting a whole
bunch of mortgages that's not wealth
building
having a whole bunch of houses that
nobody can take away from you because
they're all yours that's well
see the difference yes yes definitely
love it well hey come visit us soon hang
out have some cookies and uh some uh
coffee here at the the at the Ramsey
Cafe
if you can pull uh George away from the
cookie bar can't stop me but that's a
good point John A lot of people that
call the show like we got rental
properties I'm like how much you making
they're like four thousand dollars a
year I'm like bro I could do Uber and
make this instead of having all this
risk in my life I know but it's we're
wealth building nope not when you're
making slim profit margins you're making
a mortgage lender very very well here's
what you're doing yeah hey that's that's
another hour of the books here on the
Ramsay show stay tuned we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
incredible relationships I'm John
deloney joined by my good friend George
Campbell and we are taking your calls on
your retirement on your income on your
workplace on your marriage on whatever's
going on in your life with your kids
going back to school triple eight eight
two five five two two five whatever
you're working through we're here to
help triple eight eight two five five
two two five um George off air you were
telling me about this article that they
mentioned Dave Ramsey and tell me yeah
that's a popular Trend John uh I think
it gets more clicks and Views so they
just like to be like I did I do
something different then Dave Ramsey and
here's why I'm a genius I'm like okay
whatever so this one but this is what's
different this one is very interesting
this is close to seeing I think Dave
Ramsey's right as you can get I break
this Dave Ramsey rule every day and I'm
starting to rethink it that is the title
of the article from Chris over at the
Motley Fool that is like when
um your husband never ever ever helps
with the laundry or dishes and his
response is
well I'm sorry that your feelings are
hurt right and so like my apologies that
you have a problem right this is close
man this is almost so here's their
situation uh he says over the past few
years I've gotten into the habit of
using my credit card from nearly all
expenses I've got a prime Visa it gives
me five percent cash back on Amazon and
varying levels of cash back on other
purchases at the end of the year I have
this money for cash back rewards I put
it towards Christmas or Vacations or
whatever and he says using a credit card
almost daily breaks one of the Cardinal
rules of Dave Ramsey's debt-free living
strategy he recommends not having a card
at all while that may seem extreme I get
it I recently lost track of how much I
put on my credit card and was surprised
to see the amount and so it reminded him
of how quickly credit card balance can
grow if you're not paying attention and
I don't know if you've seen the news
lately but uh We've hit a record America
where number one at a lot of things and
we've had a Wild record of a trillion
dollars in credit card debt alone
so congratulations so he ends this
article saying looking at my card
balance has caused me to consider
changing my credit card usage so that my
balance doesn't take up any higher
here's the hilarious part John
Motley Fool makes money of course from
pushing Financial products largely debt
products and so in this article is a
pitch alert highest cashback card we've
seen now has a zero percent intro APR
until nearly 2025 and it's like if using
the wrong card could be costing you some
serious money our experts love this top
pick which fears feature zero percent
intro APR for 15 months and insane cash
back rate of up to five percent so
right right above that ad it says it
ends with this
if you're like most Americans it may be
time to take an honest look at your
credit card balance right now I did
recently and it's helped me get back on
track it may be painful at first but I
promise you'll be glad you did
here's a new credit card
I just don't I mean I get we all got to
put food on the table but this is a
funny article to put in an ad for a
credit card
I today sent a text to my manager who
said hey there's an ad um you guys are
you interested in this and I said my
Integrity is not for sale
um and so you do have to put foot on the
table and you have to sleep at night and
my goodness yeah but I appreciate his
honesty realizing this person who by the
way is very financially aware he works
for the Motley Fool and is a writer on
Personal Finance topics and even he's
like hey it got out of control there for
a second guys turns out you're five
percent on Amazon is not worth the
rewards because turns out you spend more
on Amazon which means you're not winning
financially by making Jeff Bezos so
whoever runs the place any richer so uh
this is a question we get a lot John and
I know a lot of people it's the it's the
biggest hill that I will die on that
other people are like no I'm not cutting
up my card this guy's insane and I'm
like you're you're insane you're the
brainwashed one not me and I've lived
now without a credit card I cut mine up
back in 2013. I had an Amex the Delta
Sky Miles Card I was like I'm gonna game
the system bro I'm gonna get this flight
to see my family for free I had to
discover with the rotating cashback so
it was like oh restaurants five percent
this month I'm gonna go eat out more to
then game the system bro I'm gonna
really stick it to him and then I was
four thousand dollars in credit card
Tech going like
I I I'm losing and you got to check for
forty dollars right yes cash back I got
this uh message the other day someone
who was like Hey I have the Costco
credit card doesn't it make sense to use
it for the four percent on gas it's up
to seven thousand limit I'm like okay so
seven thousand four percent you're
talking like 500 bucks a year is Max if
you're spending 600 a month on gas which
very few people do and she was like yeah
I'm not gonna spend that much on gas I
was like so we're gonna play this game
pretending that we're only gonna use
this Costco card for gas in order to get
300 bucks a year back I was like that's
bad math at best especially when like
we've talked about before
um I can't speak for Costco uh in fact
Costco probably is not involved in this
but when it comes to like credit card
miles and stuff like that uh flight
miles
those companies aren't our friend like
like the the airline companies are like
you know what dude we're so happy that
you use a card with our face on it we're
like gonna give you free flights it's
not how that works
um guys like me
gain the system I use that card I rack
up miles and I get free flights and it's
that single mom who
the child support check didn't come in
and she got her hours cut because her
boss is a jerk and she has to do it to
survive and she doesn't have any money
to pay the bill the next month that
she's the one with late fees that are
paying my flights and I'm not playing
that game and for those of you out there
who are going oh here goes John with
this whole single no let me read you a
direct quote from a Federal Reserve
study on this we estimate an aggregate
annual redistribution of 15 billion
dollars through credit card rewards from
less to more educated poorer to richer
and high to low minority areas widening
existing disparities
so it's reverse socialism it's the poor
are paying for the wealthies
um free stuff yes and now a lot of
people John they go well it's not my
fault John that they suck with money why
why should I not benefit from a broken
system
what do you say to that
that I refuse to participate in a free
flight
that comes at the expense of a mom being
able to take care of her kids I refuse
to play that game so you're saying I
would much rather the credit card
companies
um
charge single moms no late fees then
give me a free 250 flight is what I'm
saying I don't want to play that game
well what's interesting is a lot of
people also say well John it's not
coming from it's not coming from the
interest it's it's coming from the swipe
fees they charge to retailers so I dug
into this I looked at Capital One 2022
annual report turns out two-thirds of
their credit card Revenue comes from
interest fees interest fee aka the
people who are struggling yeah a third
came from swipe fees which is just
screwing retailers which then just pass
on that to you making all of your stuff
more expensive so there you go credit
card and I think I think
um uh Blockbuster is a great is a great
example if your business is built on
your customer failing
eventually your business goes away
period if the only way your business
wins is if your customer Blockbuster
didn't make their money on rentals they
made their money on late fees and that's
why they would never budge on the late
fees because that was how they made
their money they bet on their their
company survived because their customer
was failing and eventually somebody said
I'm taking that model away right if your
company is built on helping your
customer win that's longevity right so
this goes away at some point it can't
continue in the way it is yeah well I
dare all of you out there just try to
put that credit card away for 90 days
and see if it changes how you spend if
it doesn't go back to your old life but
I'm telling you it'll change how you
look at money and it will be painful as
the Motley Fool says and it's worth it
every time we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
but to talk to Emma what's up Emma
hi Don I'm sorry about my friend John
what's up
no you two are like my daughter's
favorite personality so oh I know is
your daughter nine
yes see I knew it that's about our demo
here with our maturity level
right right what's up uh Hey thank you
so much for for taking the call
um so I got a job during the pandemic uh
for a big global company I was told I
was going to be remote
um but worst case scenario you know I
have I live very close to an office so I
could just go into that office
everything was going to be great well
I'm now being asked to relocate or
resign my job
um unfortunately I have about 30 days to
make a decision
um I've been told that if I decide to
relocate I'm going to have up to 12
months to relocate which is good news
um the company has gone through a few
rounds of layoffs in the last year so
I'm a little bit concerned about kind of
how things will continue to develop in
the next 12 months
um we've paid or maybe maybe step two we
paid 160k in debt in the last bit over a
year we have 40K to go which we were
going to try to pay off by November and
just be done but now I'm wondering if we
should go into storm mode and really
prepare for whatever's coming or if
because we have in theory 12 months we
should pay off the debt and then really
save up for for whatever is coming all
right so George is going to answer this
question but I want to throw something
at you is that okay
yeah and this is for you and everybody
listening to the show
if you ever find yourself saying the
word or
we have to do this or this
you've backed yourself into a corner
without realizing it and I always want
you I want everybody listening no matter
what decision it is
to do the um intellectual exercise to
think of one or two other options they
may be crazy options but at least put
another option out on the table because
as you're talking I'm thinking this
company owns every bit of the cards
because I guarantee you if you went to
them and said okay I'll move but you
have to guarantee me three to five years
they would say we can't do that
so you have to give up your home you
have to give up your community you have
to give up your original agreement with
no guarantee that you get you move and
they're like yeah we laid you off
and you would ask him right now but no
no we wouldn't do that they but they
won't they won't put in writing they
won't guarantee it so I'm thinking as
you're talking
if you are making this kind of money and
you are this good
somebody else with a little more
stability and integrity would hire you
yes I I agree John have you thought of
another job I agree
yeah so so I'm definitely you know
looking at all options right now right
and and that's definitely an option
um I think you know what I don't want to
do is to give up the job I have in the
next 30 days
um so you know either way you know it's
good to have more time to then kind of
see how things play out
um we're just kind of wondering you know
right now uh you know do we just hold on
to money right as we kind of explore
these options
um so yeah
so where would you be relocating to
tree okay we would have to yes sell our
home lose one income
um because my spouse would have to
um yeah everything his his job as well
and then you obviously moving away from
family
um yeah so there's a lot of big big life
change okay and is there a pay bump that
goes along with this
uh so I've asked for those details I'm
supposed to be giving some more
information on that next week
um my my guess is that it's going to be
lower than what the cost of living
change will be because it will be a
anywhere from like 15 to 20 higher cost
of living where we're going okay are
they covering all the relocation
expenses
or is there a certain are they giving
you twenty thousand let's
they won't tell you how much they're
gonna pay you they won't tell you how
much they're going to cover on their
move what is it about this company that
has not because if you were dating a guy
like this
um where are we gonna live I don't know
will you marry me you have to tell me in
30 days or we break up
um what do you do for a living I'm not
gonna I'll tell you later 30 days we're
gonna break it you would you would tell
that sucker to walk what is it about
this job that is so captivated you
You're Gonna Change you're gonna blow up
your entire life for a whole string of
maybes
right so yes what John told me with you
I I'm not you know we're not 100
committed to to making this change in
fact you know our preference would be to
stay
um you know we're definitely looking at
all the opportunities and I absolutely
know where you're coming from and that's
how we feel I feel a little bit bullied
and pushed out to be honest that's
exactly I think you're going to be
resentful no matter what happens and so
for that reason I would start searching
for a different gig but I also know I
want you to be very careful about what
you're saying because I don't want this
to Circle back to anybody especially in
these kind of times so I totally get um
I get your discretion right now right
um yeah so the way I would look at this
George and tell me if I'm wrong this is
as though
um the alarm goes off in my house it
says there's a tornado warning which
means one's been cited in my county and
it may or may not be headed my way
um I'm probably gonna go down in the
basement until they give me the all
clear it's just not I mean it's not
worth it I have a bed down there I'm
just gonna go chill and so it sounds
like that's what's happened to you so it
sounds like regardless of
um whether you move or not your life is
different in 12 months and at least for
me I would go down in the basement so
the the the metaphor there is yeah I
would I would store up and save some
money there yeah the key here is we need
a clear deadline of how long if we're
gonna stay for one month I don't want
you saving for the next seven months
just in case and we don't know that's
just too long of a time to pause the
snowball when you could be making
progress so let's get some clear details
of what's next and maybe you tell them
hey if you're going to do this you have
to give me 30 days from the time you
give me all the details because right
now this is insane that you don't even
know what's happening and they're giving
you a 30-day deadline and I also know
that big companies like this will make a
move like this George
um and then they'll say oh they just
resigned all these people keep resigning
um and not fully tell the full picture
yeah no we we took them up to the very
very very edge and started hitting him
with a stick and they just they just
kept jumping right yeah of course we
just walked them down the plank they got
the option to jump into the water and
I'm like Ah that's not how that works
right yeah that's a definitely a tough
situation a lot of variables here but it
sounds like by the way you're talking
you're not wanting to uproot your life
and we've got to find another
alternative then and let me tell you
this Emma um
any frustration you hear in my voice is
not at you not even a little bit oh
I'm so
frustrated
I'm so frustrated with the corporate
culture in this country
it's destroying this place from the
inside out it's destroying families it's
destroying individual workers it's
destroying their own people are setting
their own companies on fire from the
inside out for the sake of a quarterly
stock price and it's insanity
it doesn't make any sense it it I can't
wrap my head around it other than we
gotta hit this one little metric and
we're going to burn a hole through our
entire company from floor to ceiling in
order to hit this one little dot so that
those three guys at the top get this
bonus the whole thing is so enraging
because this is the world my kids are
going to inherit and it's on fire and
they keep throwing gasoline on it
instead of coming up with an actual
solution and this is a perfect example
where they look at a family like you
who's finally established you got your
community your husband's got a job you
got kids in school and we're not going
to give you any info any of this any of
this we're going to send you halfway I
mean all the way across the country let
me know right now or you're fired you're
fired fired what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do nobody can make a good
choice like that right and the whole
thing is just so disgusting man so
um man you've got my high five to get on
out of there but I know that's easy for
me to say in the seat that I'm in yeah
that other plan so that you have a clear
path of what's next if this doesn't work
out and I'll say I'll leave you with
this and
um in these moments when these things
happen one of the things that that
resurfaces a lot for folks is self-doubt
um why me what about this what about why
me oh my gosh I can't believe
um do your best to not go there if you
have to get a couple of girlfriends that
y'all hang out and you talk you got a
place to vent do that if you and your
husband can have regularly check-ins
walks around the neighborhood once a
night or something like that do that
you're not crazy in this situation
you're not the crazy one you're not the
one who lacks Integrity it's it's the
holy stupid ecosystem with how people
are treating employees these days
um and I just need to hear me and George
say you're worth more than this you are
worth more spiritually you're worth more
emotionally you're worth more
financially and if they were gonna pay
you all this somebody else will too and
they'll treat you right this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey all month long we're giving away
cash you could win one of our 500 weekly
prizes or the grand prize of 3 000 bucks
to increase your chances enter daily at
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
also get our best-selling books like the
total money make it makeover from
paycheck to purpose and own your pass
change your future for as low as 12
bucks George you're right you just
turned in your manuscript for your first
book nothing is more fun when Dave
lowers the price and therefore the
commission on your books to sell in his
store it's awesome you can have more
people get more help at a lower price
John you know I love a good deal oh
there you go someone's winning the
altruistic George
um you can also pre-order my brand new
book building a non-anxious life you'll
learn the six choices to break free from
a life spinning out of control plus if
you pre-order today it's 20 bucks twenty
dollars I'm gonna send you a whole bunch
of free stuff to bribe you to make it
worth your while at ramsesolutions.com
store listen there's some life-changing
stuff for the cost of a trip to to
Chipotle and I know that you're jam it
is and it does cost twenty dollars now
yes inflation is real inflation is real
so you can get one meal it's delicious
oh you can change or a life-changing
book your entire life it's up to you
ramseysolutions.com
store let's go out to North Carolina and
talk to the great and wonderful Wesley
Hey Wesley what's up
hey John how you doing we're doing all
right my brother how are you
doing good good what's up man
I'm calling today because uh well our
youngest son died recently oh jeez man
and yeah we buried him in June
and uh we're my wife and I are looking
to buy a couple burial plots next to
them
but you know we're in baby step three
and uh
they're they're pretty expensive and
gosh we just can't uh can't imagine
not
being able to be one day buried next to
him yeah of course and uh leaving Malone
out there so yeah uh what was his name
Asher Asher how old was he
uh he was 10 weeks
so sorry Wesley
all right
dude I'm so sorry man
um
walk you through the um
George's gonna walk you through the
money part okay um there's a couple
things is it okay if I talk to you
pretty direct just Dad to Dad
sure okay
um
often when there's such just
insane Unthinkable loss like this
um it's easy for us to get Frozen there
too
and so I want you to hear me say this I
know you know this intellectually but I
want you to know this in your soul
um
Asher's at rest right now he's not
hurting anymore
okay
and Asher's when she takes the the when
she I want you to make a a fist can you
make a fist real quick for me
yeah sure thing and I want you to put
that right in the middle of your chest
Asher's there
so I know it feels like he's alone in
the middle of a field out in some cold
burial plots surrounded by strangers
he's right here
okay
now there is some family Legacy stuff
I'm all about I'm all about that and we
can talk through the math there
but on those moments when you can't
breathe because your son's missing and
he's scared and terrified and somewhere
all alone he's not
he's at peace and he's with you and he's
with his mama okay
thank you okay that was good
um and just as you're walking down the
street and you get overwhelmed with that
anxiety your heart starts beating on you
or you just find yourself crying in the
in a parking lot somewhere for no reason
take that and no me for a whole bunch of
reasons I'm sorry take that Fist and
just put in your chest as a reminder
okay he's right here he's right here
um
I'm gonna talk to George but I'm going
to be asking him questions about you
Wesley because I as you're speaking
um I like the idea of figuring out a way
to do that right just for a family
Legacy sake
um I like the idea but I also know
um
I'm a pretty emotional guy right and my
emotions sometimes get the better of
rational sense or mathematical sense
right so
um walk me through that well anytime
there's been anything traumatic that
happens whether it's a divorce a death
whatever it is we always tell people
don't make any big financial decisions
right now because we're not thinking
clearly and so that is my only caveat
here is I don't know the timing and how
soon this has to happen if it's going to
happen all of that but if this is
something you're saying we are doing
this I don't care what you guys say we
are buying these plots then we just got
to figure out a plan to do that and do
it in a way where we can somehow detach
the emotion from the financial numbers
of buying this thing and knowing that
like John said he's in the heart yeah
and so this may not be the solution to
the problem that you're currently facing
um is there a possibility that you can
sit down with the
um funeral home that owns this property
and say hey in six months we're going to
make this purchase are they demanding it
right now what's what's the deal here
well we spoke to him and they said that
uh they they can't hold plots
but at the same time they said if you if
you buy one plot they could hold on to
the other one for a short period of time
so that's the best they can do for us
how much are the uh plots
each plot uh it just recently went up
but it's uh a thousand dollars a piece
okay so we're talking two thousand
dollars total
yep do you have that in your emergency
fund the baby step three fund You're
Building
I do I would buy it today
would they negotiate with you if you
were able to buy both at once
now no unfortunately no that's
it's run by the funeral home but the
city owns the plots and so the money
goes to the city and their prices are
set okay
yeah for two thousand bucks
um I would do it right now
what does that leave you guys with in
your emergency fund
if we were to pay for that today that
would leave us with about 2500. okay and
then how quickly could you build that
backup
I you know I think we could probably
build it back up in a couple months
um yeah because I also want you guys to
have that Financial Security and
foundation and stability under you
because the last thing you need right
now is a financial emergency to hit
while you're grieving and all of a
sudden the HVAC goes out in the middle
of summer in North Carolina and it's
five thousand dollars and we have two
thousand
that's right so we're trying to balance
that reality with your other reality and
so
um and again I'm talking Wesley to both
you and George here um I wonder if
um a a I don't want to say a cool goal
but a goal that would be utilitarian
that would be helpful
is to say um sit down with your wife and
say we're going to buy these today and
then I am going to sign up for fill in
the blank door dash for whatever and I'm
gonna use that driving time as
I'm going to take some of this energy
and some of this angst and some of this
hurt and some of this grief and I'm
going to channel it into refilling that
emergency fund for us and it's going to
be in honor of
our little boy
right and it's going to give you some
angst and some energy and she might say
hey I need you home right now and that's
fine that's fine
um I think George is right I think you
have to balance this here and be careful
that you don't blow it all out and you
don't go do something silly and then all
of a sudden your air conditioner goes
out and this rush to make sure you keep
the family together in spirit and keep
these burial plots together indefinitely
um
becomes a nightmare because yeah you
have no you have no heat in the in the
coming up winter right
um do you guys have any other kids
we do we've got two others a
nine-year-old and a one-year-old are
those plots there too
I'm sorry for
were you asking for them I'm saying
would you buy four eventually and so you
have all five people together
yeah yeah I I think that would be ideal
is one day we
get a whole strip we're just we're kind
of worried that you know somebody's
gonna you know bind plots up next to
them and yeah but yeah
um I think George is right
um as much space as you can put between
you and this purchase I think is healthy
and keeps you from just rushing off and
trying to feel better right this second
because you're hurting so bad the nerves
are so raw but also for two thousand
bucks I would probably you have the cash
I'd probably just do it um and then you
think a little bit more long term about
additional plots for the whole family we
love you man and we're grieving with you
and I want to send you a copy of John
deloney's book on your past change your
future as well
[Music]
thank you
today's scripture of the day is John 15
2. every branch in me that does not
produce fruit he removes and he prunes
every branch that produces fruit so it
will produce more fruit George Eliot
says it's never too late to be what you
might have been I love that quote that
was 1800s John it's never too late to be
what you might have been you said that
in a way like they had words back then
Joe it just feels very like hip you know
what I mean uh so for like 1800s George
Elliott to be spitting bars like he's
just putting out a tweet for the day
it's just impressive to me I like it I
like it all right let's go out to
Phoenix Arizona where it's 1 billion
degrees and talk to the great Noah
what's up Noah
hey guys
um just to give you a little background
I am a senior in college right now I'm
looking to do PhD school
um I have about a like a six month
emergency fund I've been working uh all
throughout college and I have zero debt
so I have my emergency fund and I've
been investing into retirement but uh
unfortunately I don't have enough to
completely pay for the PHD programs or
basically any PHD programs without
taking on debts
um so I was wondering if that's
something I should reach into my
emergency fund for should I stop
investing to a retirement and what's
your guys's recommendations are for that
what's the program you want to go get a
doctorate in
I wanted to do Quantum Computing focus
in electrical engineering have you sat
down and met with an advisor of a
potential University
yes I have uh professors lined up I've
talked to
most of those doctoral degrees they pay
you
yes but they're uh with some funding
sometimes so it's usually about thirty
thousand and there's no guarantee that
you get the sponsorship for it you can
have some of the school paid off but
with uh with a decent amount uh like uh
if if there's a discount with the TA or
any lab assistant I still won't have
enough without having to pull out some
loans there
have you isolated yourself to a single
School
uh no not yet okay I would ask around
my first PhD I paid for out of pocket I
borrowed a jillion dollars for it my
wife did too
my second one I got my employer to help
out with
and I was able to cash flow the rest of
it but mostly the employer paid for
almost all of it
and so it was a huge difference
but I also waited I went to a little bit
different program than I was I was
expecting on on the get-go ended up
changing my life so it was a good thing
um but it's kind of like finding finding
a house in a neighborhood like that's
our Dream Home it has to be this one and
you end up buying way more house than
you can afford when there's a great
house right over there that you can
actually get into and have paid off in a
couple of years you see what I'm saying
so hear me say this
um I just I can't sit here in good faith
until you need to take out a bunch of
student loans to get a doctorate in
Quantum Computing do you want to go be a
professor why do you even need a PhD
uh most uh industry research is done
with a PhD okay um the big boy computers
and learn how to do that I got that yes
sir um okay could you get into the
workforce for a little while and
continue to save up and punt this thing
a year or two
I've I've thought about that at least
with some of the other professionals
I've talked to who have gotten the PHD
they say it's pretty hard to do that and
it extends your uh PhD program at least
in that field by a year or two so it'd
be another year or two of uh
dissertation prep yeah but that that's
true that is true and also I'm going to
tell you one important thing
um I hired a whole bunch of people over
the years and one of the biggest
challenges I ran into was talking to
really brilliant 26 year olds with
doctorates
and the problem was they had a PhD or 26
or 27 and so they they needed
uh salary X
to cover their their student loans and
you can't have an entry-level employee
with a doctor that just is weird but
they did not have the work experience to
have earned that level of leadership
potential because I know the the degree
is great but man you got to get in there
and learn how to lead and learn how to
run stuff and do stuff and so I often
found myself coaching students who had a
master's degree or were considering that
go work for a few years
and get some wisdom how this thing works
what's the Avenue and then you're gonna
find out okay here's the right way
someone's a company's going to look at
you and say hey you're worth investing
in uh like what happened to me and it
changes everything but I I get what
they're saying dude over the course of
your life an extra year on your
dissertation who cares who cares man
um over it feels like eternity when
you're in in undergrad and you're doing
your degree in three or four years an
extra year feels like your whole life
when you're in your doctorate and you're
36 years old and you took another year
when you were 28 and nobody cares
especially if you cash flowed the whole
thing and your business and your boss
paid for 75 of it
gotcha okay so what's it gonna What's it
gonna cost if you did this out of pocket
completely
I think
golly yeah but what but let's let's
what's the ROI right what's the quantum
Computing what would your if you had a
PhD and you walked out and got a job
with one of the big companies what would
your starting salary be
yeah pretty I think I'm pretty sure I
would do a lot you're good with numbers
very pretty high you know about 350.
yeah yeah around there yeah so if you
know what you're doing with those big
boy computers um you can make some good
money so it I'm not knocking the field
I'm all about it and I've got two of
them so I'm all about getting a PhD too
I love the learning I love being that
environment I love it all
um what I didn't love is
not being able to breathe for 10 years I
didn't love looking at my wife who
thought everything was okay and I felt
like I was lying to her every day
because I was so scared and so anxious
that we owed so much money and we
weren't safe right
um and her husband was a hot head who
had the ability to get fired at any day
on a day's notice right and so all I
have to say is I can't good faith tell
you to go take out money on that if
you've got it in your emergency fund and
George correct me from I would not have
a problem with that if you got the cash
on hand I'd quit investing and I would
cash flow and I'd be all about that man
um but if you're gonna go take out loans
I wouldn't do that gotcha okay sounds
good yeah thanks for the call man my
conclusion just keeps going back to this
guy is so he's at least twice as smart
as John at least five times as smart as
me I'm like he can find a way
to do this without debt
um I think that's going to be the best
path imagine graduating with an
emergency fund while investing making
350 and no debt versus and the ability
to run a computer that can I don't know
alter humanity take over the world I
mean this is some Doctor Strange level
stuff it is it is they are creating
Inception and reality the quantum
compute Computing stuff is so that's way
beyond my pay grade but what isn't is
saying we're going to find a way to do
this without debt and that means getting
creative and it might mean taking a
pause and maybe he gets in the workforce
and realizes actually what I really want
to do is this well and that's what I was
trying to communicate it happens to a
lot of graduates where
I've gone to school from K-12 and then I
go straight into my undergrad I crush it
my professors love me because they see
they see themselves in me right someone
who loves learning they love the
material they love the scholarship they
want to keep going in school and so
they're of course saying dude you need
to go you need to go you need to go and
a year feels like your whole life
and that's when you have to talk to
somebody who's been down the road and
they say no no I'm 40. it slow down
right just take a year go work you're
real real smart you may find out that
all right I love Quantum Computing but I
can make 350 working for uh for you know
a hedge fund company because with my
Computing skills or my code writing
skills whatever you might find that man
I don't want to make a four or five or
six year investment into this one thing
there's this sun cost fallacy because
you're like I'm already six years in I
have to do this there's no other path
now and that also frightens me I mean my
career pivoted 17 times before I got to
where I am today it was music that I was
going to be in film and I really like
marketing and then I jumped over and
started communicating and so and now
you're a YouTuber when you're in your
20s it's the time to try a whole bunch
of stuff so this may be it I mean it
sounds like he knows the exact path he
wants to go down but I was also very
sure of myself in my 20s going I know
exactly what I'm going to do and the
next year it was something different
that's exactly right but he's so much
smarter than me that I'm like I trust
this guy I trust his ability no question
about that um for everybody out there
wondering about school I think what he
did was wise always go talk to a couple
of people who are on the other side of
it on the other side of schooling on who
are sitting in the career you want to be
in someday and that's usually a great
great place to find and a good reminder
we've got a free live stream all about
student loans oh there we go on the 12th
so you can go register for that at
ramseysolutions.com student loans we got
Dave Jade and Rachel On That September
12th 8 P.M eastern time you can register
for free very very cool Emily great job
back there in the booth the rest of you
guys y'all are getting there appreciate
all your work uh George great show and
for you America thank you so much for
joining us and giving us your most
precious resource your time go out there
and take care of each other be kind pay
off your debts this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]